so this is the second film you've
directed the first was Coriolanus a few
years ago when you signed on to work on
this film was it always going to be in
the form of directing it and acting in
it or were you at first just going to
direct it well I think the first thing
to say is I I was quite I didn't expect
after making Coriolanus I'd certainly
hoped I might direct something again but
I didn't know what it was going to be I
never imagined that I would be doing a
victorian-era drama centered around
Charles Dickens and Nellie Ternan but I
was given this screenplay by Abby Morgan
and and then I liked it very much in it
I had I knew very little about Charles
Dickens and you'll be surprised to hear
I hadn't studied Charles Dickens at
school
lots of Shakespeare but no Dickens and I
I read the screenplay and I was very
intrigued by the story by her - by
Nellie and then I was so intrigued I
immediately got hold of the book which
is a brilliant book and if anything in
this film is interested you at all I
really urge you to buy this book because
it's it's really interesting about
actresses in the 19th century theater
and it starts off setting the scene for
what it was like to be an actress in the
19th century and then introduces the
turn and the history of the turn and
family the mother played by Kristen and
it's a fantastic piece of research and
very very accessible not not at all dry
or or difficult to to become involved in
and so that that really got under my
skin and this lots of reasons really one
of the things that moved me was Nellie
the story of Nellie and particularly in
Abbey screenplay the idea that there's a
woman looking for closure about a past
love a past intimate relationship and
although of course it's about Charles
Dickens and that's another element that
was fascinating to me I didn't know much
about Dickens and Claire Tomalin
description of Dickens this crazy highly
energized famous writer but there's so
many things about him that are
interesting and of course in this this
part of Dickens his life that we see we
see it and a side of Dickens that
perhaps well I didn't know much of
which was the very abrupt and possibly
cruel way he left his family and his
wife for Nellie and that's always when
when biographers write about Dickens and
they get to this bit they usually and
they're usually admiring and pretty in
love in love with Dickens but when they
get to this part of his life they they
find it hard to grasp the nettle but one
of the things that I love when I watch
films is what the sound not thus the the
soundscape is doing and how that can add
a lot of atmosphere and tension but I
just was experimenting really with ways
of creating atmosphere or somehow
ambushing the audience's expectations I
actually preferred less music in films
to more and but rather this the sound
I would rather emphasize the sound
escape of a film than the music and so
some of these places might be places
normally that you'd put music in but I
actually just I think I just said let's
see what happens if we just take the
sound out because it gives you a sense
of where are we what's happening it
doesn't yeah it's where it suppose it's
a storytelling atmospheric thing that
just I just came across and liked it
even though there have been multiple
films made based on Dickens as work if
I'm not mistaken there hasn't been a
film made about his life do you have a
feeling or an opinion on why that is
no I don't it's really odd do you'd
think that because his life is amazing
his total life is certainly rich in in
in indeed in things that would you think
would make a movie when I couldn't find
any movie where Charles Dickens the man
was Wood had been had been recreated and
interpreted so I don't know why that is
I don't know why it's it's it's
surprising we spoke a couple of days ago
in front of an audience with felicity as
well and I asked her a question about
the two sides to her performance the the
younger side the older side the Nelly
versus the
Allen I'd be curious to know how you as
a director helped her craft the two
sides of her performance because she
really did see them as distinct sides
one of the things that I admired admire
and admired about Felicity was her
ability to sort of really inhabit an
interior world within herself and I
wanted an actress who I felt could by
simply what she was doing in in here and
here could suggest a young a young girl
and then this older older Nelly who's in
her late thirties early forties and she
has this sense of sort of reserved about
her which I really liked
because of scheduling reasons and
availability of actors and all kinds of
things we had to shoot all the Margate
scenes the beat that the school scenes
first so it was not ideal because I
clearly she would love to have played
younger Nellie and then the older Nellie
so but funnily enough it was that she
seemed to have uncanny access to that
the older Nellie I mean there were like
the scene in the the graveyard at the
end which was you know difficult scene
she hadn't been able to play the whole
part before she so but she she was
stunning in that scene the way I believe
that that's an extraordinary piece of
screen acting when she has to speak
literally on the page it's what you
would call a speech and she has to
inhabit it and find it and I ever and
she did three or four takes which I
thought all had amazing things in them I
think it was more tricky playing the
younger Nellie we had to so chart the
peaks and the troughs the highs and the
lows of when she would crack when there
would be moments we would see her her
her vulnerability and have fragility and
that was something that we both sort of
had to figure out a bit more but she
always came extraordinarily prepared and
ready and always sometimes I think on
set the adrenaline makes me probably a
bit
sometimes bit brusque but she was always
very tolerant and always very courageous
when I would be pushing for her to
explore something else and I think
that's the thing that I like as an actor
is that I am pushed to go to areas I
hadn't anticipated and she was certainly
incredibly courageous in trying to honor
what I was asking of her is that a
change in the dynamic where the actor is
calming the director down now they were
raising their eyes to haven't know
what's he on about now no no I mean I
was I was blessed with an amazing crew
and cast who you know I believe and
they're not they're not here to
contradict me but I I believe there was
a very good collective spirit a
collective sense of common endeavor on
the film and clearly there were days I
mean I think there were definitely days
when you know you're wrestling with that
Kristin Scott Thomas who's extremely got
a very highly refined sense of what is
truth what's truthful for her and I have
a you know she's an old friend and I
have huge respect for her she would
quite rightly challenge me on on
something line that didn't feel quite
right that that a phrase or a New
Orleans or something she would say I'm
not sure this is right and I'd say well
okay let's find let's find a phrase or
something that would work and I mean you
know you you there are healthfully there
are good creative moments which are
sometimes full of a healthy kind of
tension which is the debate of trying to
get to the heart of something and those
and you know I'm like I learned I'm
learning that those things you know they
come at you and you're directing and
actors say I don't understand why am i
doing why do I have to do that and
that's and that's what I would probably
ask certainly I would probably